Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO DPU. Herzlich willkommen. Willkommen. Das, das, das Podcast UFO. Willkommen. Willkommen. Das, das, das Podcast UFO. Willkommen. Hey, ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dieses Intro jemals aufgenutzt zu haben. Danke! Dricko. Aber auch zu Recht, du hast eine ganz tolle Folge abgeliefert, einen tollen Beitrag abgeliefert und du wirst zu Recht von der Community gefeiert. Die Leute lieben dich, ein bisschen zu sehr, finde ich.
Ja, wir sind ein bisschen neidisch.
Kommt alle ein bisschen wieder runter.
Wir haben noch nie so viele positive Kommentare bekommen.
Thais ist, wer es nicht weiß, unsere Schülerpraktikantin, die diese Woche ihre letzte Woche bei uns hat, danach geht es wieder zurück in die Schulzeit.
Krass, wie lange warst du jetzt da?
Wahnsinn.
Andereinhalb Wochen.
Einerhalb Wochen schon.
Es kommt mir vor, es wären es ein Dreiviertel. Hat meine Lehrerin eigentlich schon angerufen? Mich nicht. Oh, nee, mich auch nicht. Tatsächlich, wir haben angekreuzt, man dürfte ankreuzen in dem Vertrag für das Schülerpraktikum, ob wir besucht werden möchten oder angerufen werden möchten, noch passiert es nicht. Und es ist tatsächlich ein Albtraum, dass ich irgendwo in einer ganz unmisspassenden Situation angerufen werde. Ja, hier ist Frau Kreisler. Ich finde es übrigens zwei ganz schlechte Auswahlmöglichkeiten. Entweder besucht werden oder angerufen werden. Kann man hier einen Kreis runter gemacht und Mail. Einfach schreibt uns eine Mail. Kurze Telegram-Nachrichten, kurze GIFs einfach. Ich verstehe nicht, warum sie... Ich finde, sie sollte auch eine Bewertung bekommen. Nicht nur die Schüler und ihr kriegt auch eine Bewertung von mir, wie das Praktikum so lief, sondern auch die Lehrerin, weil sie sich überhaupt nicht um kümmern. Evaluation, gibt es dann auf der Uni, kannst du das dann machen. Ja, gib deiner Lehrerin mal eine schöne Sex. Sag einfach so, Frau Kloppenberg, das war nix. Zack, sechs. Einfach schön so ein Trauersmalchen noch draufmalen. Und ja, macht einfach mal schön mit Areal, setzt so ein schönes Dokument auf und dann gibst du immer so ein tolles Zeugnis zurück. Finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ihr dürft euch natürlich wieder auf fantastischen Content freuen, denn Thais hat richtig abgeliefert. Nicht nur hat sie wieder eine ihrer fantastischen Reportagen, Thais-Reportagen nenne ich sie mittlerweile, abgeliefert, sondern sie hat auch unglaublicherweise ... Wo war das Wortspiel? Ich denke, seit zehn Minuten übernacht. Wegen Weiss-Reportage. Oh Gott, holy fuck!
Ich hab sie tagelang übernacht.
Ein Plus für die Mühe.
Okay, danke.
Und sie hat es tatsächlich geschafft, einen Sponsoren an Land zu ziehen. Wir sagen noch nicht wer. Freut euch darauf. Das heißt Cash, Cash, Cash.
Für Thais, wir haben es wohl angekündigt, haben wir es angekündigt, dass Thais, wenn sie einen Sponsoren an Land zieht, auch wirklich dann das ganze Geld dafür bekommt.
Und dann Das Cash, Cash, Cash in Thais Taschen. Für Thais, wir haben es wohl angekündigt, dass Thais, wenn sie einen Sponsor an Land zieht, auch wirklich dann das ganze Geld dafür bekommt. Und wir haben auch nicht spezifiziert, welcher Sponsor. Es kann wirklich alles sein. Es kann wirklich der Dichtungsringhersteller hier um die Ecke sein. Wir wissen es nicht, wir sind alle sehr gespannt. Ja, es gab viele Möglichkeiten, aber ich habe natürlich die Beste genommen mit Moral.
Bei dir geht es ja nicht ums Geld,
sondern natürlich auch ums Gewissen. Also du bist eine engagierte Schülerin. Du hast tatsächlich,
muss man auch mal sagen, Stefan, ich weiß nicht, ob du es weißt,
ich möchte, dass du auch mal da kritisch wirst,
du hast am Freitag dein Praktikum geschwänzt.
Was? Zwei Wochen lang
solltest du bei uns sein, aber am Freitag
hat sie ihr Praktikum geschwänzt, um die Umwelt zu retten, das Klima zu retten, die feine Dame. Jetzt gehen wir also auf die Strasse und werfen Steine auf Polizisten. Der Winter war total kalt, wo ist denn deine scheiß Erderwärmung? Eigentlich war das nur, weil ich ein Interview führen wollte für euch, aber ich wurde abgewimmelt. Meine alten Freunde aus einer Partei, wo ich früher war, jetzt aber nicht mehr. Du kannst schon kommunistische Partei sagen, ist schon okay. Nee, nee, die Grünen, die Grüne Jugend Düsseldorf hat mich abgewimmelt. Vielleicht war ich ein bisschen zu cool für sie mit dem neuen Fame. Nee, Spaß. Nee, sie wollten einfach kein Interview führen, meinten so, wir geben keine Angaben. Und ja, deswegen ... Und hast du gesagt, dann lass ich das Praktikum einfach sausen, und jetzt halte ich mein lächerliches Schild hoch mit fünf Rechtschreibfehlern und keinem coolen Spruch, und dann wird für die Umwelt protestiert, ja? Ja. Nee, ich find's okay. Ehrlich gesagt, ich auch okay. Das ist halt genau das Ding, da haben wir letzten Wochen drüber gesprochen, man kann ja nicht böse sein, du tust was für die Umwelt. Auf der anderen Seite wäre, du tust was für das Podcast-Ufo. Ich glaube, meine größte Angst ist einfach, dass ich in 100 Jahren in so einer N24-Doku vorkomme, wo es dann heißt, die Jugend engagierte sich, wurde aber zurückgehalten von den konservativen Alten und dann wird ein Ausschnitt aus dem Podcast-Ufo gespielt, wo Stefan und ich Thais kritisieren dafür, dass sie sich engagieren. Das will ich einfach gar nicht. Deswegen, liebe M24, ich unterstütze das, ich finde das gut. Auch für die Zukunft. Und hört nicht die letzte Folge. Auf keinen Fall. Wie ist es dir ergangen? Was hast du mitgebracht? Ich bin ganz gespannt. Was hast du erlebt? Gerade hast du mit Bela B gesprochen. Unfassbar. Es war krass. Ja, ich habe, glaube ich, wieder zum Punk zurückgefunden. Ich weiß noch nicht. Zurück zum Bela B hat's geschafft, Thais zurück in die Fänge des Punk. Ist Bela B noch Punk? Nee, eigentlich gar nicht, oder? Was hat er für Schuhe angehabt? Ähm, silberne Schuhe, silberfarbene Schuhe, Stiefel. Okay. Sieht man in der neuen Neo-Magazin-Folge. Okay, gut. In der Florentin auch eine kleine Rolle spielt. Ja, ist richtig. Und ja, jetzt riecht sie nach Bier, dank ihm. Er hat Bier auf mein T-Shirt geschüttet. Also, Bela, nicht ich. Bela B. Florentin, wir haben gesagt, kein Bier auf die Praktikantin. Aber ich meine, wenn das nicht Punk ist, wenn du von Bela B. mit Bier beschüttet wirst, ich weiß nicht, was einen noch zurückholen kann zum Punk, wenn nicht das. Ist das das Bier, was hier gerade steht? Ja. Was du mitgebracht hast? Ja. Das Mühlenkölsch? Ja. Das war nicht der Sponsor. Das war nicht der Sponsor, okay? Überweist trotzdem gerne Geld an thais at gmail.com. Ja. Ist das jetzt der erste Podcast, der unter alkoholischem Einfluss stattfindet, Stefan? Stefan hat ein Bier genippt. Nein, habe ich nicht. Nee, okay. Nee, ich habe vor allem noch einen Kaugummi im Mund. Kannst du mal eine Hand ausstrecken kurz?
Hier hinten ist der Mülleimer.
Ist der Mülleimer da?
Nee, der ist hier die Tür raus.
Wir müssen aber noch einen Praktikumsbericht schreiben für Thais, ne?
Ich muss selber einen schreiben, ihr müsst nur Sachen ankreuzen.
Wie ankreuzen?
Seiten!
Das Leben ist so einfach.
Das Leben ist so einfach auf Arbeitgeberseite.
Du musst so Dinge ankreuzen.
Du musst acht bis zehn Seiten schreiben.
Was?
Aber ganz kurz, das fällt mir diese tolle Geschichte ein, weil ich habe ja auch
Vielen Dank. Du musst deine Dinge ankreuzen. Du musst acht bis zehn Seiten schreiben. Was? Aber ganz kurz, das fällt mir diese tolle Geschichte ein, weil ich hab ja auch ein Praktikum gemacht, und zwar ein Pflichtpraktikum für das Studium. Da gibt's nur eine kurze Praxiszeit in einem Semester. Und es war genau die Zeit, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es mir erzählt hab, aber es war genau die Zeit, wo hier die Sache mit Erdogan war. Weshalb die zwei Wochen, wo ich es hatte, dieses Pflichtpraktikum, ist die Sendung in New Magazin ausgefallen, wo ich das gemacht habe. Perfekt. Ich musste ja trotzdem jeden Tag eine gewisse Stundenanzahl absolvieren. Man musste auch wirklich so einen Praktikumsbericht ... Da hast du mit Anmelden gequatscht. Du hast das Praktikum beim New Magazin gemacht, obwohl du da trotzdem schon gearbeitet hast. Ja habe schon gearbeitet, genau. Und da musste ich halt wirklich jede Woche, jeden Tag musste ich online Tagebuch führen, was ich gemacht habe. Stundenweise. Und das musste man online machen, das heißt, man konnte sich auch wirklich nicht drum rum mogeln und so, man musste es halt tagesaktuell machen. Und ich dachte mir, fuck, was mache ich denn jetzt, kann ich behaupten, dass ich nicht gearbeitet habe, weil es war einfach Urlaub, es war einfach für alle frei, für alle Mitarbeiter in dem Zeitraum. Und dann habe ich einfach angefangen, mir was auszudenken. Und ich habe einfach gedacht, fuck it, jetzt tue ich so,
als hätte ich am ersten Tag eine Sendung gepitcht. Wie könnte diese Sendung heißen? Nennen wir sie mal Larry 3000. Ich habe Larry 3000 gepitcht und dann ist das ganze Praktikumsbericht, ist dann die Geschichte von Larry 3000 gewesen, wie es gepitcht wurde, wie es unter Tränen eingestellt wurde. Erst sollten die Folgen 120 Minuten sein, dann 40, dann gab's Casting-Entscheidungen. Dann war es am Ende nur noch ein GIF, es gab Casting-Entscheidungen. Ich hab zwölf Folgen geschrieben, man war das wie in Nächte durchgearbeitet, und am Ende wurde es dann eingestellt, und dann habe ich wieder beim Neomagazin angefangen. Das war wirklich, und ich habe das bestimmt acht bis zehn Seiten Bullshit, aber ich habe am Ende eine gute Not dafür bekommen, und ich glaub, mir wurde sogar Glück gewünscht mit Larry3000 weiterhin. Bei guter Arbeit wollten wir lange diese Lücke füllen, diese Blase, und Larry3000 wirklich in die Tat umsetzen. Niemand wusste, was es ist, und daran ist es auch gescheitert. Aber es klingt gut genug. Ich glaub, wir haben sogar die Domain registriert, Larry3000.de, damit die Geschichte so ein bisschen Glaub ist. Aber es gab alles, es gab, es war wirklich, es war unter Tränen, wurde das Projekt am Ende eingestellt, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich es auch irgendwo finde, aber Larry3000 ist die Geschichte meines Praktikums. Aber du sagst acht bis zehn Seiten Praktikumsbericht. Ja. Das können wir ja nicht alles hier vorlesen, oder? Können wir irgendwie so Ben Becker engagieren, dass der das vorliest, einfach so? Ich hatte sowieso vor, den Wikipedia-Artikel von der BTF erst mal zu kop kopieren sehr gut das sind schon mal so eine seite und ja dann kannst du unsere kopieren ein bisschen bei einer eigenen seite einfügen und die über meine schuhe ja ja ach so die gibt schuhe hat eine
eigene profopedia seite ich weiß es nicht also, ein Fan auf Instagram hat mir geschrieben, ob meine Schuhe einen bekommen sollten, da meinte ich so, haha, warum nicht? Okay, interessant direkt. So muss man das betonen, ich habe das anders betonen, haha, so betont man dein haha. Naja, ey, ist nochmal ganz grosses Sorry, wir haben ein bisschen Gegenwitt bekommen, dafür wie wir mit dir umgegangen sind, ich dachte wir müssen eine Praktikantin auch, wir müssen die ein bisschen auf den richtigen Weg schubsen so. Wir müssen auch streng sein, das ist wie so ein junges Pflänzchen, wo man auch mal ein Blatt abschneiden muss. Ja, aber wir haben uns vorgenommen, Good Cop, Bad Cop, am Ende war es Bad Cop, Worst Cop tatsächlich so ein bisschen. Aber naja, es tut mir auch ein bisschen leid, aber ich finde wir, also sorry nochmal für letzte Woche. Ja, alles gut, als alte Punkerin kenne ich nicht da aus. Ich entschuldige mich nicht, Ich finde, du bist dadurch ein besserer Mensch geworden und darum geht es mir. Nicht darum, dass du mich magst, sondern dass du besser wirst. Mir geht es nur darum, dass du mich magst. Ich glaube, ich wäre ein schlechter Vater. Waren eigentlich eure Eltern das Podcast-Ufo? Ähm, nee. Das ist so ein Thema, das wir gerne verdrängen werden. Nein. Lustigerweise... Aber glaube ich, alle Frauen, in die jemals verliebt waren, hören diesen Podcast, glaube ich. Das auf jeden Fall. Echt, die von den ich weiß. Die von den ich weiß. Hört diesen Podcast? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Aber ja, Avril Lavigne, Avril Nisbiers, Stacey Urico. Ich war mal in Stacey Urico verliebt, und immer wenn ich sage, Stacey Urico, weiß niemand, wer damit gemeint ist. Niemand weiß, wer das ist. Klar, wer Stacey Urico ist. Das ist das Problem, wenn du so einen Celebrity Crush hast, den niemand kennt, und dann ist es einfach so ... Oh, mein erster Celebrity-Crush war Kim Possible.
Oh ja, ich glaube, wir hatten ...
Nee, für mich war es noch Misty aus Pokémon.
Da glaube ich, ich bin noch ein bisschen älter.
Nee, da eher Rocco.
Der noch Knuffenser, das auf jeden Fall.
Der noch Celebrity-Crush.
Rosanna.
Ach ja.
Sorry, ich habe mich ein bisschen verloren.
Wer ist dein Celebrity-Crush, Thais? Meiner, im Moment. Pfff. Wie? Sean Mendes? Bela B. Ja. Nicht Sean Mendes? Nee. Ähm ... Ich schaute gerade sehr angewiesert. Five Seconds of Summer. Kenn ich nicht. Ich kenn fast gar keine. Ich hab eine Cousine in deinem Alter, deswegen habe ich gerade diese Sachen. Dir hat übrigens auch den Podcast. Darf man sagen, wie viele Hörer ihr habt? Für den Sponsor musste ich das rausgraben. Ja, aber hast du ein bisschen übertrieben, hast du gesagt, so, ja, schon einige? Nee, ich habe auch Screenshots geschickt mit den wirklichen Anzahlen, also halt. Ja, wissen wir auch selber nicht genau. Ich bin da leicht fälschen, so eine Spotify-St eine Spotify-Statistik, das sind doch nur Zahlen. Das kannst du ja einfach ändern. Ja, aber ich war schon erstaunt. Ich war erstaunt. Es sind insgesamt auf Spotify und iTunes 132.000 Hörer. Pro Woche. Ja. Krass. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele da noch über diese Apps hören, die direkt auf den RSS-Feed zugreifen. Ja, es gibt ja auch Deezer und so. Das ist, glaube ich, eher kleiner, aber diese Podcast-Apps, Podcatcher und so. Ich glaube, da kommen auch noch ein paar dazu. Also, schwierig zu sagen, wir wissen es nicht. Wir können auch unsere Seite nicht richtig auslesen, wo man das herausfinden könnte, weil wir ein bisschen zu dämlich sind. Und an wen bist du jetzt herangetreten mit Sponsoring-Möglichkeiten?
Das möchte ich bitte für die Mitte der Folge aufgeben.
Du, weil du das Thema angesprochen hast.
Ja, bei Podcasts kann man ja keinen Daumen runtergeben, ne?
Apropos, ich habe Florentin gesehen, er war bei Dislike.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, ist richtig. Aber Moment, kann man denn überhaupt einen Daumen hochgeben bei Podcasts? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Also auf iTunes kann man nur so Sterne geben. Sterne. Ja, bei iTunes meist, oder? Genau, bei iTunes. Ich bin ein bisschen lost in diesem Moment. Worum geht's? Wie ist Dislike abgelaufen? Ich habe gehört, Stefan hat diese Dislike eingeladen. Dislike ist ein Format, wo einem Tweets vorgelesen werden, wo man beleidigt wird.
Und dann geht es darum, dass man darauf antwortet.
Und dann habe ich da ganz viele Tweets vorgelesen, die mich beleidigt haben.
Und ich war überrascht, weil ich dachte eigentlich, ich bin so ein glatter Typ irgendwie, ich habe keine Ecken und Kanten und erfahre sehr wenig Hate und habe dann aber sehr viele negative Kommentare abbekommen, was mich gewundert hat.
Und am Ende wurde aufgelöst, nein, die Kommentare waren alle gar nicht echt, sondern die hat alle Stefan Tietze geschrieben.
Ja, das war ein großer Jux,
kundig diese Folge gerne an.
Aber, ja, ich finde es aber auch
ein bisschen traurig, weil
du nicht... Ja, ich habe echt mein Leben überdacht, ich will es ein bisschen mehr anengen.
Du warst danach wirklich ein bisschen traurig,
dass du so wenig polarisierst.
Weil lustigerweise alle deine grossen
Idole, wo du dann mal wieder
montagsmorgens ankommst und sagst, wow, kennst du den Comedian, der ist toll. Und es sind meistens Leute, die wahnsinnig polarisieren, die viele Leute einfach nicht mögen, wo du dann auch zu einem kleinen Kreis gehörst, der einfach diese Leute abfeiert. Und diese Künstler polarisieren alle sehr, das ist dein Ding, aber lustigerweise polarisierst du gar nicht selber. Beziehungsweise vielleicht, ich weiß nicht warum, oder es ist einfach so, dass Leute sich dann nicht nur finden, wenn sie in der Nische eh schon sind. Ja, ich glaube schon. Aber kannst du davon ausanalysieren, warum ich so glatt bin? Ja, ich glaube halt nur die Leute, die wirklich das, was du machst, feiern, schauen dich auch. So sehr, dass sie kommentieren könnten. Genau. Andere beschäftigen sich vielleicht gar nicht so sehr bis zum Kommentar.
Aber ich finde es interessant, weil ohne deinen neuen Beitrag zu hören, dein Alter war so klasse, ich würde dir gerne anbieten, ich habe da nicht mit dir gesprochen, dass du ab und zu mal Beiträge für das Podcast haben.
Ja, haben wir auch schon darüber gesprochen, kannst du gerne machen.
Ich fände es super cool.
Das wäre auch eine Idee, einfach mal so ein Profil über uns zu erstellen, gerne mit dem Psychologen, gerne warum kommen wir bei Leuten nicht an?
Oder warum kommen wir bei Leuten an? Warum hat Florian keine Feinde? Oder hat er Feinde? Ich habe einen Feind. Ich hatte während meiner Schulzeit zwei Theaterbesetzungen, ich war im Theater-AK und wir waren zu viele Leute im Theater-AK, dass wir zwei Besetzungen für das selbe Stück gemacht haben. Es sah ja aus wie, du hattest nur so eine Narbe durch die Sicht. Ja, genau, eine Schnurrbahn einfach. Und jede Rolle wurde also mit zwei Personen ausgestattet. Ich habe die Hauptrolle gespielt und natürlich habe ich dann extreme Feindschaft angefangen, mit der anderen Besetzung Hauptrolle, der meiner Meinung nach Grottenschlecht gespielt hat, der mittlerweile an der Otto Falkenberg studiert und ich dort abgelehnt wurde. Aber das ist mein Erzfeind. Von daher, vielleicht eines Tages begegne ich ihm wieder und dann werde ich ihn anknurren. Aber ich finde es so lustig mit Blick auf früher. Aber fandest du jetzt immer noch, dass er schlecht gespielt hat? Oder war das eher so eine sehr, sehr subjektive, eingenommene? Wir haben die Rolle auch anders ausgelegt. Ich habe die Rolle sehr ernst gespielt. Welche Rolle denn? Das war dem Stück Hotel zwischen zwei Welten oder Hotel zu den zwei Welten von Erik Emanuel Schmidt. Ich habe es noch nicht gesehen, aber es ist relativ häufig, wie es so gespielt wird. Ja, ja, klar, das ist auch gut. Du schick mal die Flasche auf. Da geht es um ein Hotel, das zwischen Himmel und Erde ist und alle Menschen, die sozusagen kurz vorm Tod sind, kommen in dieses Hotel, metaphorisch, und dann entweder sterben sie und fahren nach oben oder sie leben weiter. Ist das auch ein bisschen lustig? So, und das ist nämlich das Ding. Du bist es wahnsinnig tragend gespielt. Ich habe es irgendwie so richtig wehleidend und dann gibt es eine Liebesgeschichte, was super awkward ist, wenn du irgendwie 15 bist. Und bei ihm im Publikum alle, wuuuuh, bei dir alle, oh, eingepennt. Dann gibt es so eine Kussszene und so und das ist alles schrecklich. Und er hat das halt sehr lustig gespielt und halt sehr locker und ha ha ha und alle haben gelacht und damit fand ich mich verletzt in meiner Künstlerehre. Ja, du musst ein bisschen aufpassen. Ich passe auf, ich passe auf. Naja, weil du hier mit deinem Fuss so rumwippst. Nee, ich passe schon auf auf das Kabel. Thais, wenn du vielleicht ein Auge drauf hast. Ich passe auf das rote Kabel auf. Ich passe auf. Ich habe meine Knöchel unter Kontrolle. Also das möchte ich nur sagen, ich habe einen Feind, der mittlerweile mir voraus ist. Ich habe auch einen Feind, den neu gewonnen. Du machst gerade Videos. Du kannst nicht, ich finde, iPhones brauchen ... Ohne Scheisse, jetzt kann Rüge, Rüge, Rüge. Rüge ausgesprochen, das reicht, glaube ich, schon. Ich finde, das finde ich eine Idee, und die kannst du morgen beim Patentanwalt, kommen wir gleich darauf zu sprechen, einreichen. Ich finde, datenschutzmäßig finde ich es richtig gut, wenn iPhones vorne eine rote Lampe hätten, wenn sie aufnehmen. Weil ohne Scheiß, so oft wie ich irgendwann, nein, passiert nie, aber ich habe das Gefühl, Leute filmen einen. Oder du jetzt zum Beispiel hast einfach uns gefilmt und es sieht furchtbar. Aber man sieht es nicht einfach, weil du hältst dein Handy einfach hoch und man denkt, du liest irgendeinen Artikel. Ja klar ... Ja, klar, da hast du die Jugend von heute gut verstanden.
Du liest einen Artikel über ... einen Theis-Artikel.
Ach, kommt schon, Leute, wegen Weiss!
Das war der gleiche Gag.
Ist okay.
Nee, aber ich finde, wegen Datenschutz.
Okay, ja, ich finde ...
Zum Beispiel im Fitnessstudio neulich hat ein Typ einen anderen einfach gefilmt, weil er so schwach war.
Hat sich über den lustig gemacht.
Also dich.
Hat mich gefilmt.
Nein, aber das habe ich gesehen und ich fand das wahnsinnig uncool. Kann ich kurz ein Video machen? Ja. Aber ich meine, kannst du ja nicht mit Gesichtserkennung arbeiten, dass wenn jemand, dass du dein Gesicht in eine Datenbank einspeicherst und immer wenn jemand anders dich filmt, dann sagt der, ah, bling bling, sie müssen erst die Erlaubnis einholen und dann kommt bei dir ein Pop-up. Person XY hat ein, schreibt das mal auf für das Patent, Person XY will ein Foto von ihm posten und du sagst ja, nein, siehst das Foto auch und dann hast du auch keinen Datenschutzstress mehr, weil du weißt, alles, was hochgeladen wird, gepostet wird, ist automatisch schon dadurch. Oder einfach so eine grelle Lampe, einfach die vorne am iPhone, so eine rote grelle Lampe, die alles wegflext. Und Und es wird halt default-mäßig so ein Emoji über deinen Kopf gelegt. Aber dann könnte ich ja gar keine ... Geheimen Insta-Stories mehr von uns machen. Völlig richtig, darum geht's. Gar keine geheimen Storys mehr, aber für euch machen. Ja, genau das ist ja darum. Für euch. Für uns. Für uns. Ja, wenn ich das Bild sehe, würde ich sagen, es ging. Du hast gerade eine Rüge bekommen. Du hast gerade eine Rüge bekommen.
Okay.
Du hast gefilmt.
Wie viele Rüge sind ein Tadel?
Drei.
Drei Rügen sind ein Tadel, drei Tadel ein Verweis.
Eine Abmehnung.
Ein Verweis?
Wie viele Verweis?
Nee, Verweis ist das Grösste.
Ja, fünf Verweise, du kriegst einen aufs Maul.
Okay.
Ich kann, ich tu mir leid, ich kann einfach nicht autoritär wirken, oder? Das geht nicht. Würdest du mich akzeptieren als Lehrer oder würdest du dann irgendwie so Papier in meine Haare werfen? Ich glaube, es ging, es ging. Das ist das Schlimmste, was dir eingefallen ist. Papier, deswegen hast du keine Feinde, weil du bist wie so eine, du weißt, du bist, was Angriffe angeht, so eine Qualle am Strand, so wehrlos, einfach, und man kann einfachihen drücken. Sind Quallen am Strand echt tot? Ja, die sind ausgedrückt. Wenn Kinder mit denen werfen, ich denke mir, holy shit, das will man mit keinem Tier machen. Ja, aber Quallen sind auch so ein bisschen... Wir gehen dann auch keine Luft mehr, wenn die draussen nehmen. Quallen sind wirklich so zu 99,999% einfach Wasser. Wo man auch sagt, Leute, ein bisschen mehr.
Wenn die Augen hätten oder wenn die irgendwas hätten, was nicht aussieht wie kein Lebewesen.
Ein bisschen mehr zumindest, zwei, drei Prozent.
Ich finde, Qualle...
Nase, Nase war gut.
So Plastiktüten, ist das alles Umweltverschmutzung oder sind einfach Quallen?
Man weiß es auch nicht.
Und diese Kisten, die man immer sieht, in denen sich Delfine verfangen haben.
Das sind einfach Kistentiere.
Es gibt ja auch ganz viele Fische, die versuchen, so auszusehen wie Korallen oder so.
Vielleicht machen das alles nur bei Plastikmessern.
Und das sind überhaupt keine Plastikmesser im Ozean, sondern alles nur diese Fische.
Und man denkt sich...
Ja, wo wird das bei Fridays for Future?
Ja!
Gehst du da wieder hin diesen Freitag?
Wenn du wieder hin gehst, ist das die dritte Rüge?
Nee, die Frage ich zur Aufnahme. Beim Neomagazin? Nee, am Freitag. Kommenden Freitag, übermorgen. Da ist ja wieder die. Da ist keine Aufzeichnung. Ach so, ja, aber wie lange war das, am Set? Du bist am Set? Oho. Ja. Also dann doch kein Naturschutz mehr. Dann ist die Umwelt doch scheißegal. Nee, aber ich kann ja übernächste Woche gehen. Einmal können die auf mich verzichten. Okay, klar. Gut. Es fing doch locker spaßig an mit dir. Mittlerweile stellt sie eine Forderung, ihr könnt ja auch mal einen Tag auf mich verzichten. Sie hat vor allem innerhalb von einer Woche sämtliche Prinzipien verraten, da kommen wir später noch dazu, sämtliche Dinge, für die sie mal stand, hat sie verraten innerhalb von einer Woche. Hast du Prinzipien, hast du so mal Prinzipien verraten, wo du wirklich gesagt hast? Ich glaube, die mache ich schon häufiger, ja. Es ist aber auch menschlich. Ich finde, es ist schon normal, dass man ab und zu seine Prinzipien einhaufen wird. Nee, als ich Punk war ... Es ist nur gut, wenn man dann so reflektiert ist und es checkt und dann besser macht. Als ich Punk war, war ich alles. Ich war also entweder bei mir eine Phase, in der ich nichts mache wirklich. Also es gibt nur zwei Extreme. Nichts oder wirklich auf 100 Prozent. Weil als ich Punk war, war ich Veganerin, ich habe mir ein Piercing stechen lassen, ich habe mir Schuhe gekauft. Also wirklich all in gegangen. Ja, all in. Und ja, ich war Veganerin.. Ja, ich war Veganerin und es ist schon krass, wenn die Freunde ein Eis essen gehen und ich so sage, nee, die Kühe haben es nicht verdient. Bist du eigentlich noch Veganer, Florentin? Ja, wie lange hast du das gemacht? Wie lange hat er deine Punkphase angehalten? Meine Punkphase so... Was ist Punk denn vegan? Was ist denn... Ich verstehe früher, aber. Für mich ist Punk ... Wir treten Läden ein und schmeißen ... Treten Läden ein. Ja, und schaffen's dann nicht, weil die Türen sehr stark sind, die Fensterscheiben sehr ding. Nee, das war Punk bei uns damals nicht. Bei uns war es einfach Punk, wir machen laute Musik vor Kirchen. Ja, ich dachte, Punk ist so diese Schnorrer-Szene. So dieses Rumhängen und Geldschnorren und so, das ist für mich Punk, jemand so irrokratisch.
Das sind Obdachlose.
Für dich ist Punk vegan sein, das erheblich aber auch nicht gesagt.
Für mich ist Punk, die Welt zu einem besseren Ort machen zu wollen.
Nee, aber Punk ist erstmal gegeneistlich, ob das Punk ist. Wir wissen auch zu wenig.
Nein, auch gegen die Gesellschaft und so, und vegan ist ja auch nicht den Standards folgen. Mach mal eine Punk-Reportage für uns. Ja, mach mal die Punk-Szene in Deutschland. Ja, ich kann die Punks auf der Strasse an Düsseldorf fragen. Frag mal, was ist für sie Punk? Was bedeutet das für sie? Sieht's man Punks? Was ist für sie Punks? Punk, Punk sein. Und dann piekt sich so in die Nieten. War das nicht so eine Prank-Sendung? You got punked? Auf MTV? Niemand ausser dir hat jemals MTV geguckt, glaube ich regelmäßig. Ich mochte Punk'd. Mit Ashton Kutcher. Sagt ihr gar nichts, ne? Ich schaue immer in diese leeren, grossen Augen. Als Erste, als sie angekommen ist, haben wir uns zusammengesetzt und ich habe ihr fünf Namen genannt und bei keinem einzigen wussten. Aber ich bin auch schlecht in Celebrities. Also ich kannte den Namen Jason Derulo in der siebten Klasse nicht. Aber wo die ganze Klasse ausgerastet ist, so was? Und ich so, ja, Jason Derulo. Ich lese halt solche Sachen nicht. Weil wenn man seinen Namen singt, vor jedem Lied, was clever ist, muss man sagen. In Zeiten, wo der Radiomoderator nicht immer mehr anspricht, von wem der Song ist, finde ich einen Jason Di Rullo und jetzt kommt mein Song, finde ich nicht schlecht. Würdest du mal an Stefan Tietze singen? Stefan Tietze. Namen, die sie nicht kannte. Bastian Pastewka. Cordula Stratmann. Christoph Maria Herbst, Annette Frier, Annette Frier,
wollte ich auch sagen, Cordula Stratmann, mir fallen keine mehr ein, wir haben Anke Engelke, Markus Maria Profitlich, Bono, Bono, Bobo, DJ Bobo, doch, den kenne ich, den kenne ich, das war dabei dein Song dabei, der blieb schon. Der kommt da jetzt auch nach Deutschland, Warte, wir haben so ein Poster hier mit dieses Harvard Drops.
Der ist tot.
Der ist tot?
Ja. Wie? Der piep ist tot? Das ist fun. Der ist gestorben. Schon wieder weg. Kurz bevor ich verstanden habe, was es ist, sind wir wieder weg. Immer das Gleiche. Habt ihr die ganzen Werbungen in Köln gesehen, wegen Karne? Ja. Werbungen? Ja klar, Plakate. Warum gibt es Plakate für Karneval? Für Deitas. Wir sind tatsächlich, und das ist eine absolute Fügung des Schicksals, und ich bin sehr, sehr froh, nächste Woche Karneval in Wien. Ach, ihr will hier so. Wir sind gar nicht da, und es ist perfekt. Ja, perfekt. Es ist großartig. Ich wollte mich fragen, ob ihr mit mir feiern geht. Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich versuche immer das Land zu verlassen während der Karnevalzeit. Oh, ich habe dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal Lust darauf, weil ich das ganze Jahr nichts gemacht habe, nicht rausgegangen bin, kein Privatleben hatte. Da dachte ich mir zum ersten Mal jetzt Karneval vielleicht. Und dann gehst du in deinem Chewbacca-Kostüm raus. Nee, aber vielleicht dachte ich mir, es ist einfach mal, weil es ist eine coole Veranstaltung, um mal unter Menschen zu kommen. Es ist super cool. Auf eine Art, mit der ich gut klarkarkomme, nämlich mit dem Kostüm an, du kannst eine andere Rolle schlüpfen. Du kannst andere Star-Wars-Fans sofort erkennen. So, man kann erkennen, wer zu welchem Areal der Menschheit gehört. Und das ist einfach, alle sind gut drauf und so, die Musik ist furchtbar zwar, aber du kannst auch in den Länden gehen, wo die Musik gut ist. Und ich denke mir, das wäre erst mal dieses gut gewesen. Was wären denn die Top 5 Stefan-Tietze-Kostüme gewesen? Kostüme gewesen, gute Frage. Definitiv Platz 5 ATSD. Platz 4 Chebacca. Platz 3 Greedo. Platz 2 dieser hellere Wookie. Und Platz 1 Sebulba natürlich. Nee, ich weiß nicht, was war, dass, ich fag's einhorn. Du wärst ein Onesie-Typ. Das wollte ich ganz sagen, wie unkool ich das finde. Du würdest dir ein Tierkostüm anziehen? Nein, auf keinen Fall. Ja, aber da kommt man doch ganz schwer wieder raus. Ich dachte, die Idee ist, dass man sich schneller ausziehen kann. Ne, ich glaube, das ist so eine Art, also... Nein, das ist einfach nur die Idee, dass es nicht, weil an Karneval ja immer, da ist immer kalt draußen und da möchte man nicht, keine Ahnung, mit einem Kettenhemden nur stehen, sondern schön kuschelig eingepackt sein. Und man muss sich keine Mühe geben. Einfach rein, Reisverschluss zu. Ich finde das furchtbar. Ich finde das ein ganz schlimm trend. Du wärst ein Känguru. Aber Jacke drüber oder Jacke drunter? Ja, keine Jacke. Da braucht man ja keine Jacke. Nee, die sind warm. Weil an Karneval sind alle eigentlich nur als Jacke verkleidet. Ja, das stimmt schon. So wie zu Halloween auch immer einfach, ah, du gruselige Jacke. Ich war vor ein paar Jahren Halloween der Wichser. Niemand erkannt hat. Du hast verhaftet. Ich sah genau wie der Wichser aus, mit diesem Zylinder und so einer Totenkopfmaske, sah wahnsinnig furchterregend aus, aber hat niemand erkannt.
Sagt dir das was? Sagt dir der Wichser was von Oliver Kalkofe?
Nein.
Was für ein Leben lebst du denn?
Christoph Maria Herbst?
Aber was ploppt bei dir auf, wenn ich sage Deutsche Comedy?
Was ploppt auf in deinem Kopf?
Sag mal die fünf Assoziationen, Deutsche Comedy, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Weiter, weiter, weiter, Assoziationen, nicht nachdenken.
Ja, ich schau das nicht so oft, Till Reyners, Moritz Neumeier.
Ja, weiter? Aber ganz anders.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Sagt dir Loriot was?
Loriot, ja.
Okay, na gut, gut. Monty Python?
Nein.
Aber gute Arbeit, gute Arbeit.
Du, der dafür kannten wir Little Peep nicht, es ist halt einfach unterschiedlich.
Aber Karneval ist so eine Sache, da freuen meine Freundinnen und ich uns schon seit letztem Jahr Karneval drauf. Schon das ganze Jahr kann man auch sagen. Die fünfte Jahreszeit. Ah ja. Wir kommen ja aus Düsseldorf, der ist ja auch Karneval gross. Und als was verklärst du dich? Und ich weiß es noch nicht. Ich bin immer sehr spontan. Nee, ich muss noch schauen. Ich habe noch gar kein Kostüm und ich war bei Deitas. Scheiße, es war richtig schlecht, die hatten einfach... Ich wollte hier... Das ist so eine Jugendsprache. Was ist das? Ich kenne Deitas nicht. Deitas? Das war nicht so fly, oder? Das ist halt so ein Karnevalsladen. Der ist doch ganz rare, oder? Ich gucke mir jetzt mal kurz Jugendbegriffe an, und dann versuche ich ihn mal einzustreuen. Der ist nicht so knusprig. Der ist nicht knusprig. Der, ähm, nee, da haben die nur komische Kostüme gehabt, und vielleicht werde ich wie letztes Jahr einfach Koala. Ah ja. Einfach Onesie. Mhm. Das ist ... Da ist mal Schluss zu. Das mag ich nicht, ich finde das wahnsinnig unkreativ. Das ist einfach so, du siehst dir immer was an. Aber es ist kalt. Vor allem in diesen Karnevalsläden in Köln ist das Wahnsinn. Wenn du irgendwie, weil ihr hat ja seine individuellen Interessen heutzutage. Mit dem Internet hat er jeder, kann sich in seinen Scheiss rein nischen. So, und dann finde ich, du kannst in diese Läden gehen, die sind so gut sortiert, du kannst ungefähr eine Vorstellung haben, wie du aussehen willst, und du kannst das alles zusammenstellen, weil die einfach alles haben.
Die haben alle Masken, die haben alle Umhänge in allen Farben und so. Du kannst tendenziell einfach dein eigener Superheld sein. Du kannst so viel machen, und dann ziehen sich die Leute einfach so ein Fell an. Aber ich habe eine Theorie. Ich glaube, es ist etwas Fairy-artiges. Ich habe eine Theorie. Wer sich am meisten Mühe gibt, also je mehr man sich Mühe gibt beim Kostüm, desto uncooler ist man und desto mehr Aufmerksamkeit möchte man auf sich ziehen. Die coolen Kids ziehen sich einfach so, wollen sie, so kleine Hörnchen auf dem Kopf, dann war's das. Die uncoolen Leute wollen sich ein ganz körperkostüm für 500 Euro kaufen, um dann einmal im Mittelpunkt zu stehen, um einmal bewundert zu werden. Du hast gerade die komplette Cosplay-Szene fertig gemacht. Nee, Cosplay ist ja was anderes. Aber an Karneval da wird eh alles verpläckert. Warum machen die am Karneval nicht Cosplay? Was? Warum macht man am Karneval kein Cosplay? Verstehst du ihn nicht? Warum macht man das nicht? Wörter wie Fly oder Squatch oder Squatch oder so. Aber ist es dann nicht cremig, wenn man dann irgendwie an einem Karneval ... Nein, abbrechen. Ist die Frage so unverständlich? Nee, ich verstehe es schon, aber ... Keine Ahnung, was andere Antworten soll. Du hast vor der Teilzeit-Tazahn, oder? Du verstehst Karneval einfach nicht. Vor allem Teilzeit-Tazahn. Das stimmt. Hat das wirklich irgendwer, oder denkst du dich, dass diese ... Hast du mal Teilzeit-Taz. Das habe ich noch nie gehört und noch nie benutzt. Diese Jugendwörter, das ist irgendwie auch, wer macht die denn? Ist das so ein Jury, der sitzt und tagt und tagt, also wirklich, ich meine, da gibt es ein Buffet, da gibt es, da stehen so Apollinaris-Flaschen, diese Glasflaschen, wo mehr Glas als Wasser drin ist am Tisch. Das sind dann fünf alte Männer, aber die haben alle das Cap falschrum an, die machen dann die Jugendsprache. Ja, es gibt glaube ich gar nicht mehr so viele neue Wörter, wie die immer reinbringen müssen. Deswegen müssen sie sich mal ausdenken, wie Smombi oder so. Ich habe es noch nie gehört, wie jemand es ernsthaft benutzt hat. Das war ja Jugendwort des Jahres 2017. Ja, völlig. Aber gibt es in Wien auch sowas wie Karneval? Ist das Fasching? Fasching? Ist das zur gleichen Zeit? Nicht, dass wir jetzt irgendwie von einer Hölle in die nächste reinfahren und dann da irgendwie total im Chaos sind. Was ich gerne machen würde, ist so Karneval in Venedig mit diesen Masken. Rio de Janeiro, mal so richtig Karneval. Oh ja, Samba-Zamba. Ja, diese Masken in Venedig, wo man einfach, wo man erkennt sich noch. Und es gibt auch diese Oper, der Maskenball von Verdi, wo es die ganze Zeit darum geht, dass man sich nicht erkennt auf diesem Maskenball. Und die haben diese, beim Könner Karneval würde das verstehen, Verdi hätte zum Karneval diese Oper schreiben müssen. Ich glaube, er hat auch einen Karneval gehabt. Weil da erkennt man Menschen nicht, wenn sie wollen, dass man sie nicht erkennt. Aber beim Maskenball in Venedig haben die einfach diese dünnen, oder manchmal hat man nur so einen Schnurrbart, wo man auch sagt, ihr wusstet, wer der andere war. Aber es ist ja ganz praktisch, weil du kannst ja so tun, als würdest du nicht wissen, um wen es geht. Und dann kannst du die Frau deines Herzens ansprechen und so tun, als wüsstest du nicht, wer das ist. Herr Verdi, haben Sie das so gemeint? Nein? Okay. Was meinst du, Thais? Wie würde Verdi in der heutigen Welt leben eigentlich? Hinten Sie Verdi? Ja. Ja? Was würde der so machen? Puh, schwierige Frage. Ist keine leiche Frage. Wahrscheinlich kiffend in seinem Zimmer sitzen, voll mit Drogen, Tätos im Gesicht. Im Gesicht? Ja. Im Gesicht? Das ist jetzt eine neue Sache. Ja. Ein grosser Verdi im Gesicht stehen. Und so ein Dollarzeichen. Donner im Mobile. Und ja, würde er einen Song nach dem anderen produzieren,
innerhalb von 20 Minuten. Würde er Instagram Stories machen? Ja. Okay, cooler Typ. So wie du.
Apropos Instagram Stories, wir kommen jetzt zu einer kleinen und erstmals in diesem Podcast
eingeführten Rubrik, das haben wir in unserem Podcast bestehend noch nie gemacht, und zwar, jetzt kommt Werbung.
Das Podcast-Ufo-Werbung.
Werbung.
Wie machst du es eigentlich, wenn du Veganer bist und auf dem Set bist?
Muss man immer dein eigenes Essen mitnehmen?
Kannst du dich fragen, gleichstellen, wobei wir sind in der Werbung geprägt.
Du kannst dich einfach ... Das ist eine Rüge gewesen.
Auf keinen Fall. Eins, zwei, drei, go! Biologisch abbaubarer Werbeblock. Bracenet sucht den Eco-Fluenza. Man merkt, wir haben da keine Erfahrung. Fang nochmal an. Eco-Fluenza. Fang nochmal an. Biologisch abbaubarer Werbeblock.
Bracenet sucht den Ecofluenza.
Jedes Jahr werden hunderttausende Tonnen Fischernetze in Ozean...
Falte Stimmung, falte Stimmung.
Ich will den Text vorlesen.
Jedes Jahr werden hunderttausende Tonnen...
Warte, stopp, da muss man doch von Anfang an fangen.
Jeder...
Biologisch abbaubarer Werbeblock.
Bracenet sucht den Ecofluenza.
Jedes Jahr werden hunderttausende Tonnen Fischernetze im Ozean entsorgt, in denen von Flipper bis Nemo so ziemlich alles verendet, was schwimmen kann. Bracenet will das ändern. Gemeinsam mit den Meeresschutzorganisationen Healthy Seas und Ghost Fishing bergen sie die Netze weltweit mit 150 Tauchern und fertigen daraus in Handarbeit Armbänder, das sogenannte Bracenet. Dein täglicher Reminder, die Plastiktüte oder den Coffee-to-go-Bächer mal sein zu lassen. Wenn auch du die Verschmutzung des Meeres nicht mehr tatenlos mit ansehen willst, hat Bracenet jetzt das richtige Produkt für dich. Werde der erste Ecofluencer. Als Ecofluencer reist du drei Monate um die Welt, um die schlausten Lösungen zum Meeresschutz vorzustellen. Du fragst in Kenia, wie sie es geschafft haben, Plastiktüten zu verbieten, du fährst mit auf Bergungsfahrten, führst Interviews mit Politikern und postest Videos von deinen Erlebnissen.
Du musst kein Instagram-Star sein, nur über 21 Jahre alt, aufgeschlossen, Englisch sprechen
können, wissen, wie man ein Video schneidet und nicht bei der ersten Welle über der
Reling hängen.
Klingt spannend?
Dann schicke ein kurzes Vorstellungsvideo an ecofluencer at brace.net.
Ein Senderschluss ist der 28.
zweite Laptop, Kamera und benötigtes Equipment, Reisekosten, Übernachtungen und Bepflegung gehen auf Bracenet. Mehr Infos auf bracenet.net slash ecofluencer. Wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, dingelilingeliling. Das Podcast-Ufo, Werbung, Werbung. Hört sich gut an. So, das war unser Werbeblog und Thais hat den Sponsoren klargemacht. Herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu.
Und sämtliche Erträge, die wir von diesem Sponsoring bekommen,
gehen direkt an Thais.
Nicht schlecht.
Ich werde sie direkt wieder zurückspenden.
Es ist für einen wahnsinnig guten Zweck.
Ja.
Aber ich würde es da sogar selber machen, diese Eco-Fluencer sein.
Aber da muss man leider 21 sein.
Na, das ist blöd.
Und ich muss auch nicht schulieren.
Und denen hast du jetzt das Geld aus der Tasche gezogen? Ich dachte die ganze Zeit, bevor ich das gerade vorgelesen habe, dass es besser ist, für so jemanden Werbung zu machen, für eine Firma, die mit einer tollen Ideologie dahinter steht und tolle Sachen plant. Es tut mir wahnsinnig leid, aber es ist für denen, dass du denen, Thais, Geld abnimmst. Sie haben jetzt weniger Geld als vorher, um das mehr zu retten. Aber sie haben eine grössere Community gewonnen. Okay, aber wir hätten es ja auch kostenlos machen können. Aber schau mal, nicht nur gehst du nicht mehr auf die Demo, sondern du saugst sogar den Leuten, die sich für eine bessere Welt einsetzen, das Geld noch ab, um schön dir neue Schuhe zu kaufen. Was willst du denn von dem Geld kaufen, was sie nicht in den Meeren brauchen? Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht... Kauft ihr wenigstens was, was nicht danach als Müll im Meer landet. Kauft ihr keine... Erstmal schön Plastikflaschen. Schön 10.000 Plastiktüten kaufen. Aber Bracenet ist natürlich eine fantastische Sache, die am... Tatsächlich, ich habe es mir durchgelesen, und zwar gibt es Geisternetze. Geisternetze sind Fischernetze, die aus irgendeinem Grund nicht mehr an einem Fischerboot hängen, sondern selbständig unter Wasser leben.
Und die haben eigene ganze Städte eingerichtet und eine eigene Zivilisation gegründet, nur aus Geisternetzen.
Und Bracenet klaut die sozusagen den Fischern, weil sie gehören ja eigentlich immer noch den Fischern, weil was man in den Müll wirft, gehört einem ja immer noch.
Und deswegen klauen die das mehr oder weniger von den Fischern und machen aus diesen Fischernetzen so Armbänder, die man kaufen kann.
Die kann man kaufen, die sind wunderschön. Und nicht nur sind sie wunderschön, nein, sie werden sogar durch einen cleveren Mechanismus verbunden. Wie werden sie verbunden? Magnete! Magnete! Sie werden durch Magneten verbunden, das heisst ihr habt immer einen Magneten am Angelenk, was auch wichtig sein kann, falls ihr mal eine Festplatte löschen möchtet oder sowas.
Ja, falls ihr fremd geht und eure Freundin nimmt das Handy in die Hand, könnt ihr schnell, ah, zack, das Handy ist schon seit Monaten. Ah, jetzt ist eine kromische Speicherkarte gelöscht, ganz merkwürdig. Also viele gute Einsatzmöglichkeiten für das Bracenet und wenn ihr das noch mehr unterstützen wollt, wenn ihr euch für die Umwelt einsetzt, wenn ihr nicht sagt, ich gehe am Freitag lieber auf ein Filmset oder scheiße einfach drauf, dann könnt ihr euch auch bewerben als
Ecofluencer.
Sorry, das Wort haben sich so oft penetrant in diesem Artikel benutzt, das hättest du mal merken können, Ecofluencer.
Aber es ist nicht das Beste, der beste Begriff.
Bewerbt euch und werdet Ecofluencer und dann könnt ihr auch die Welt retten, im Gegensatz zu anderen, die das nicht möchten.
Ja, denn das ist echt eine gute Sache. Ich finde das wirklich ganz toll, ich kannte das vorher nicht. Und ich glaube, ich mache da gerne mit. Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden. Bist du ein Schmucktyp, also so Armbänder und so? Ja, klar. Ich mag gar keinen Schmuck tatsächlich. Aber da dachte ich mir, weil es stimmt ja, es ist ja auch eine Erinnerung daran, dass man auch im Alltag irgendwie versuchen soll, Plastikmüll zu vermeiden. Aber ich bin echt kein Schmucktyp., Ringe, Armbänder, mein Ding. Ja, auch so Funk, so Zehnringe, ah, das ist genau das. Es ist nicht nur Punk oder Umwelt, es geht auch als Zwischenphase. Und apropos, eine neue Phase hat, glaube ich, bei mir begonnen, nämlich die Filmphase, also so ein Filmset. Jetzt möchte ich unbedingt Regisseurin werden.
Sehr gut, cool, das freut mich sehr. Okay, und wie sieht diese Phase aus? Ja, also ich schaue viele Serien. Ja, welche schaust du an? Sehr gut. Darf ich sagen? Klar, ja, natürlich. Ja, also Sex Education auf Netflix. Ja. Und da achte ich ganz spezifisch darauf, dass der eine mit der dunkeln Hautfarbe sehr stark geschminkt ist, was ich natürlich besser gemacht hätte. Aber ja, ich achte da schon auf viele Sachen. Du hättest ihn wie weniger geschminkt? Weniger. Aber gehört das nicht zu seiner Rolle auch ein bisschen? Er ist auch eher so ein flamboyanter, androgyner Typ, der auch ... Du hast es geguckt? Ja. Die Teenager-Serie als 24-Jähriger? Ja, warum nicht? Er schreibt ja auch gerade Teenager-Serie. Ist ja auch ein bisschen Recherche zum einen, klar, zum anderen aber auch, weil mich das auch interessiert, was da so ... Ja, aber ... Ich hab auch The Reasons Why geguckt, ich hab Riverdale geschaut, ich hab alle diese Serien geguckt. Was ist denn dein Lieblingsfilm, wo du jetzt sagst, wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, ich will selber Filme machen, was ist ein Film, wo du sagst, so in die Richtung würde ich gerne gehen? Memento. Memento, okay, okay. Wow, wo wollt. Ja, klar. Wir kennen Dinge. Das sind guter. Ja, wir sind sehr gespannt. Was waren denn, ja, was waren denn eure Teenager-Phasen, die am meisten bereut? Ich wollte als Teenager mal Roboter werden. Tatsächlich, das hat leider nicht funktioniert. Ich habe tatsächlich noch... Ich finde, das hat ganz gut funktioniert. Gefühlskälte, check. Tatsächlich habe ich aber als junger Mensch in Poesiealben bei Was möchtest du mal werden auch immer Regisseur geschrieben. Also da sind wir, da haben wir jetzt eine Phase synchron. Cool, Thais lacht sich gerade einfach kaputt. Da sind wir gerade zusammen.
Thais lacht sich weg. Die Sponsoren haben gerade geschrieben, ich habe so ein kleines Foto.
Ist doch wieder ein Foto von uns geschickt.
Thais, hör auf, Fotos von uns rumzuschicken.
Das ist der erste Tadel.
Thais, das war ein Tadel.
Keine Reaktion.
Nicht unter Kontrolle zu bringen.
Okay, das wird ernste Konsequenzen. Wenn du noch zwei Sekunden lachst, dann gibt es einen Eintrag. Super cool, an der Plastikflasche im Hintergrund arbeiten wir nochmal. Danke, Stefan. Sehr gut. Stefan, du hast alles versaut. Toll, du hast eine riesige Plastikflasche gesehen. Das ist eine Pfandflasche. Ja und, glaubst du, wo geht die hin vom Automaten? Direkt ins Meer? Was? In den Halstern Schiffgröße. Ja, natürlich. Ganz kurz, kann ich mal kurz, ich will den mal antworten. Hallo, Ihre Beschwerde ist eingegangen beim Podcast UFO. Kurze Rückfrage, das ist ja eine Pfandflasche. Wie problematisch sind denn Pfandflaschen und woraus soll ich denn trinken? Weil jetzt hätte ich auch gerne ein paar Vorschläge. Also ich bin total pro Umwelt, nicht falsch verstehen, aber ich bin auch pro Pfandflaschen. Ich bin auch pro Umwelt. Und ich bin pro Trinken. Also wenn Sie da vielleicht konkrete Vorschläge hatten. Die Glasflaschen, die hinter mir stehen, Stefan. Ganz kurz, das ist eine Sprachnachricht, okay? Darüber reden wir gleich. Fünf Kästen Glasflaschen. Vierter Tter Tadel, Thais. Ist mir eine Versammlung. Aber ... Ich hoffe, dass es mit dem Sponsor geklappt. Wir wirken sehr unprofessionell. Die haben das schon überwiesen. Wohin ist das? Wirklich? Die haben das gerade überwiesen? Sie ist schon mit Ferrari draus. Wumm. Alba, die haben schon überwiesen. Im Jetpack. Fliegt sie einfach weg, gen Himmel. Ich hasse es. Okay. Ich trinke jetzt dieses Bier, was hier steht. Ich fühl mich gut. Ich fühl mich gut. Ich fühl mich gut. Moment, ich hab das Gefühl, wir haben was Gutes getan. Ich fühl mich besser, tatsächlich. Ich fühl mich jetzt besser. Und ihr da draußen auch, wenn ihr... Aber diese Pfannflaschenaktion nervt mich jetzt ein bisschen. Ich freue mich wirklich auf die Antwort, weil ich bin gespannt. Bestimmt, bestimmt. Die haben ja gerade eben geantwortet. Und wenn die dich hören als supergrossen Influencer, kommen wir jetzt zur neuen Rubrik, nämlich die Fragerubrik von Twitter. Uiuiui, das ist ganz gefährlich. Okay, alles gut, ja, mal weiter, sorry. Stefan, ich muss dir auch eine Bewertung schreiben, ne? Ja, kannst du dir auch eine Bewertung schreiben? Rück ihn, rück ihn. Ich finde es ja so lustig, dass dieses Kabel rot ist und wir die ganze Zeit, es wirkt wie diese Mission Impossible-Szenen, wo man sich so durchlängeln muss, durch diese Laser. Ja. Also, plant ihr mit mir dieses Jahr auf den Humorkongress zu gehen? Ja, wir planen es jedes Jahr, aber wir verbaseln es jedes Jahr aufs Neue. Wart ihr da wirklich einmal? Nein, wir haben es verbaselt, wir haben es verfrebelt, klassisch. Was sind Stephans neueste Fehlkäufe von Noel Lesto? Rucksack, da habe ich sogar mit, gestern eingetroffen, ich habe mir zwei Rucksäcke bestellt, zum Vergleich, und die haben mich für den Falschen entschieden. Problem, ich zeige es euch ganz kurz. Ja, das sind diese Sack-Rucksäcke, die sehr populär sind. Soll ich den? Nein. Der ist nämlich echt schön. Wir sind ein Audioformat. Der ist wirklich schön so, aber das ist wenn er zu ist und das muss man ja da zu machen. Und wie nervig ist das denn. Ja, mit so einem Gürtelding, wo man da immer reingeht. Holy Shit, das nervig. Und man denkt die ganze Zeit, jetzt will ich eine Wasserflasche rausholen, aus meiner Fernflasche rausholen. Dann mach ich den auf und dann habe ich schon keine Durst. Okay, also zu komplizierte Öffnung. Also ein gürtelähnlicher Verschluss. Und ich wurde davor gewarnt und habe es trotzdem gekauft, jetzt werde ich ihn wahrscheinlich wieder zurückschicken. Ich muss sagen, ich habe den noch nicht bezahlt bei Zalando und mein Ziel ist es jetzt, den einfach wieder einzupacken und zurückzuschicken. Und mal gucken, weil ich hab den jetzt mal Probe getragen, einen Tag. Das wird nur ein Tag alt. Ja, du kannst bestimmt, wenn du es sauber machst. Der ist ja sauber. Der ist von dem Leder hier, das ist von dem Leder davon. Leder? Was ist Leder? Dafür sind Tiere gestorben. Leder? Das ist Kunstleder. Was? Nee, auch nicht. Das ist aus ... Was ist aus dem Ecofluencer Stefan geworden? Dir ist schon klar, dass Kunstleder nicht verrottet und noch 10.000 Jahre im Meer schwimmt? Mir ist jetzt klar geworden, dass es ein grosser Fehler war, diese Ecofluencer-Nummer aufzuziehen. Wir sind schlecht für sowas. Wir verrennen uns jetzt. Wir sind ein schlechtes Vorbild, ihr müsst es besser machen als wir. Das ist kein Leder, das ist ... Rückt ihn ... Das ist ja auch kein Fell, das ist kein ... Das ist Fuchsgesicht, das ist nicht echt nicht echt. Jetzt kriegst du auch mal eine Rüge, Stefan.
Schon die zweite heute.
Das ist eine Rüge.
Okay.
Ich hab noch gar keine bekommen.
Nee, du popularierst ja auch nicht, du tust auch niemandem was.
Stimmt.
Ich hab die Quale am Strand.
Ich hab keinen Hate.
Von Philipp Steffen kommt die Frage, wie funktionieren Smartphone-Handschuhe?
Oh ja.
Da bin ich gespannt. Die haben an den Fingerspitzen ein Material, das elektrisch leitet und dadurch erkennt, dass der Touchscreen das. Ich glaube, dass es warm ist. Ich glaube, es sind Magneten. Nee, es geht darum, dass es elektrisch leitet, weil die Haut wegen viel Wasser leitet elektrisch und wenn du zum Beispiel eine Wiener Wurst damit auf den Touchscreen tippst, funktioniert es auch, weil die auch elektrisch leitet. Du denkst an Wien jetzt schon, ne? Das ist ein bisschen voll in Wien, in Wien-Fieber. Ja, also kann ich empfehlen, Smartphone-Handschuhe, eine Anschaffung, die sich lohnen. Weil ihr könnt damit auch Festplatten löschen, wenn ihr mal ein Problem habt, könnt ihr damit einfach über eine Festplatte kratzen. Was soll man mit Festplatten löschen? Ich habe ein bisschen gegoogelt, aber ist jetzt egal, ist ein anderes Thema jetzt. Rippkampfisch Jeff fragt, könnt ihr die erste Mensch-Kategorie wiederbeleben? Nein, das können wir, finde ich, mal wieder machen. Ja, ich finde es gut. Okay, machen wir in drei Folgen. Buchtipp, der Erste Mensch. Der Erste Mensch, der einen Buchtipp gegeben hat? Nee, Buchtipp, der Erste Mensch. Aber jetzt eine Frage, die mich interessiert. Wie überlebst du, Florentin, das Leben am Set als Veganer? Ich war nämlich auch am Set und die Leute sind ständig am Essen. Schokobong hier, Nusspackung mit Schokolade da, alles in den Mund gestopft, aber du kannst das ja gar nicht schaffen. Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein grosser Vorteil für mich, das Vegan-Sein ist, dass ich da einfach nicht snacken kann. Und das ist wirklich ein grosser und wichtiger Punkt bei mir, weil ich habe keine Disziplin... Als Veganer, als normaler, sollte man für so nicht aufrufen, entscheiden, das nicht zu essen. Ich habe keine Willensstärke. Keine Willensstärke. Aber Vegan sein ist eine Willensstärke. Ja, aber nicht wirklich, das ist alles widerlich. Und das ist der Vorteil daran, dass du nicht so gut snacken kannst und dass es generell keine leckeren Sachen gibt. Aber nur weil du das Etikett Veganer aufklebst, heißt das nicht, dass du dann Willens... das ist ja auch trotzdem eine Willensstärke. Aber es ist eine andere Form von Willensstärke. Du hast einmal die Entscheidung getroffen und dann war's. Ich kann halt nicht so dieses, ah, heute esse ich nur drei Sachen und dann noch ein und noch ein und gestern mehr. Und deswegen ist das Problem, du hast diese ganzen Probleme gar nicht, weil es einfach nichts gibt. Und irgendwann haben bei der guten Arbeit haben die Leute angefangen, ah, dann holen wir jetzt auch vegane Kekse und so und ich habe gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was ich will, damit du nicht mit deinem Snacks und so Mahlzeiten oder so. Wie viel Umweltaspekt schwingt da mit? Null, so scheißegal, ich versuche ja Warum, man macht das denn? Ach so, nee, ich versuche ja die Tiere, die ich nicht durchs Essen töte, dann aber selbst händisch zu töten, einfach um die Balance zu halten. Also ich versuche jeden Tag in Taube tot zu treten, damit das die Balance hält. Tauben sindue. Ist das ein Zitat, Tauben sind egal? Tauben sind egal. Du weißt doch die Folge, Tauben sind egal. Weil Tauben sind nicht Teil des Ecosystems. Es stimmt schon, Tauben sind wirklich egal. Die leben auch nur, also erstmal habe ich Brieftauben bis heute nicht verstanden. Brieftauben, muss man mit denen... Ständig falschen... Falsche Adresse geliefert. Aber ich verstehe nicht, wie funktioniert das Prinzip Brieftauben? Ich verstehe es auch nicht. Weil, also musst du die irgendwo hinfahren und dann finden die zurück. Ich glaube, die finden zurück. Okay, aber da muss man da hinfahren. Ich glaube, damals gab es noch keine Autos. Ich glaube, du kannst denen schon so zwei Punkte beibringen, zwischen denen, die hin und her rotieren. Wie? Auf der Kart? Du fährst die dahin und fliegst zurück. Ja, okay, aber da kannst du dem Typen auch direkt sagen, hier ist eine ... Ja, aber die können ja viel schneller fliegen, als du reiten kannst. Und du brauchst keinen Reiter. Nein, aber man kann nicht da hinfahren, weil damals waren Leute keine Ausrichtung. Ja, damals, da bist du drei Tage hingefahren, um den Weg zu zeigen, und dann bist du in der Pest krepiert. So, toll, toll, tolles Prinzip. Und das gibt's ja immer noch. Ich verstehe einfach brieftaublich. Kann man jemand erklären vielleicht. So, haben wir noch ein paar Fragen?
Ne, ich glaube, das war es für diese Folge.
Vielen Dank, das war Thais Community-Ecke. Dankeschön.
Dankeschön.
Und jetzt natürlich, worauf wir uns schon eine ganze Woche lang freuen, Thais war wieder unterwegs, sie hatte ihr Mikrofon dabei.
Thais on the road.
Thais, was hast du für uns ausgegraben?
Ja, ich habe sehr viel künstlerisches Zeug mitgeschnappt auf dem Weg und das wollte ich jetzt fortspielen. Wo warst du denn? Was war deine Aufgabe? Das hört ihr im Intro. Alles klar? Okay. Hey, hier ist wieder die Praktikantin Thais. Heute ist das Thema Kunst und dafür bin ich extra für euch zu einem Aktionshaus gefahren, um dort ein Interview zu führen. Viel Spaß beim Zuhören! Wie sieht so Ihr Berufsalltag aus? Heglich bekommen wir Einlieferungen von Kunden, entweder private oder gewerbliche Kunden, die bei uns Sachen versteigern wollen, das heisst sie kommen mit Möbeln oder mit irgendwelchen Objekten zur Taxierung. Wir begutachten diese, stellen einen Wert fest und wenn diese Kunden mit dem Wert einverstanden sind, nehmen wir die an und geben ihnen die Auktion. Das ist so ganz grob das Auktionsgeschehen. Und dann entscheidet halt, macht das oder macht das. Wissen Sie, ob hier schon mal Kunst angeboten wurde, die gefälscht war? Definitiv. Leider Gottes haben wir die Erfahrung bis öfter gemacht.
Das Problem ist, wir müssen mit unseren Kenntnissen in die Vorkasse treten.
Das heißt, wenn wir sagen, das ist echt und sich nach meinetwegen sechs Jahren herausstellt, das ist eine Fälschung, müssen wir das regulieren.
Sprich, wir müssen die Ware zurücknehmen, den Kunden ausbezahlen und das gehört uns, das heisst man hat dann sechs Donner Euro bezahlt für eine Fälschung. Also kommt durchaus vor, der Kunstmarkt, der ist halt nicht einfach, nicht jeder weiss alles und dementsprechend kann sowas durchaus vorkommen. Haben Sie auch von dem Fall gehört von Gerhard Richter, der im Moment heiß diskutiert wird, dass das Bild von ihm wurde versteigert, das aber auf dem Müll von ihm gefunden wurde? Und so ein Nachbar hat das, glaube ich, da rausgeklaut. Finden Sie denn, dass Kunst dann nicht mehr ihm gehört, sobald er es auf die Strasse stellt? Ist der Künstler für zuständig. Wir haben auch einen vergleichbaren Fall, gerade momentan. Ich darf jetzt nicht den Namen nennen, aber das war auch ein Künstler oder eine Künstlerin, die ihre Kunst entwertet hat, indem sie die Signatur durchgestrichen hat und hat ihre Kunst an die Strasse gestellt zur Entsorgung. Und irgendeiner hat diese Kunst gesehen, eingeliefert und da gibt es jetzt einen kleinen Rechtsstaat.
Das kommt auch vor. Ich finde, wenn jemand seine Kunst zunichte machen möchte, dann muss er das gänzlich machen, sprich zerstören, um solche Fälle nicht aufgetreten zu lassen. Ja, und gibt es eine Art von Mode, also jetzt zum Beispiel auch bei Möbeln oder? Absolut. Kunst, Kunst, Düsseldorfer Malerschule, Uecker beispielsweise, Uecker, Beuys, so die gängigen Namen kriegt man immer verkauft.
Für mich ist das keine Kunst, aber das war einfach die Meisterschule, da gab es fünf Schüler, die haben produziert, er hat seine Signatur darunter gepackt und dann war es ein Frank-Roch.
Wow.
Also es war jetzt nicht Frank-Roch, aber es gibt halt, das ist halt gang und gäbe. Können Sie nur anhand des Mahlstiles erkennen, mancher im Auktionshaus, in welchem Künstler ist das? Stimmt, aber nicht ich, sondern meine Kollegin, tut mir leid, ich bin da ganz der deutsche Anschluss. Aber natürlich, Mahlstile kann man erkennen. Es gibt halt bekannte Künstler, das weiss selbst ich, ich kann jetzt keinen Namen nennen, aber die haben schon ihren eigenen Stil. Na das war's, danke. Oh ja, kein Problem, noch ein Wasser? Nee, das ist richtig. Ja sorry, das war, ich habe mich nicht in die Leser, war jetzt ein bisschen, Trink aus, du musst das trinken. Nee, war jetzt echt ein dober Tag und mit der Kollegin wäre es besser gewesen, gerade wenn du sagst Gemälde, Kundens. Darf ich das eventuell auch veröffentlichen? Ich nusche, klar, kannst du machen. Da weiss ja eh keiner, ist ja kein Name dahinter. Musst aber nur schneiden, wenn der Kunde gerade reingehnt. Mach mal ein Praktikum bei uns hier, anstatt so ein Erebild zu machen. Ja, kannst du? Gerne. Drei Wochen machen wir auch. Gerne hast du gesagt. Also erst mal grosses Plus, dass du trotz dieser Geräuschkulisse standhaft geblieben bist, nie gesagt hast, ich baige das Interview ab, sondern dass sie wirklich große Baustellenfahrzeuge ziehen, vorbeidem ist durchgehalten. Wieder mal ein ganz toller Beitrag. Schöner Beitrag, schönes Interview. Das ist ja genau das gleiche Auktionshaus, wo Stefan sein Bild ersteigert hat. Das ist der Grund, dafür haben wir sie hingeschickt.
Und wir haben, finde ich, einen interessanten Blick hinter die Welt des Auktionators gefunden.
Wie hat es dir gefallen, was hat das so für Schwierigkeiten für...
Du hast gesagt, du willst ein Praktikum machen, du hast dem Herrn ins Gesicht gesagt, ja, ich würde gerne ein Praktikum machen.
Ja, also ich fand es richtig gechillt dort.
Also ich dachte, da würden so Snaps sitzen, die total streng sind, aber das war so ein ganz entspannter Mann, der, als ich mit ihm das Interview geführt habe, geraucht hat. Okay. Auf den Möbeln, die er zur Auktion fangt. Auf den Bildern? Auf den Möbeln. Die Bilder hat er aber gut behandelt. Nur auf den Jackson Pollock-Bildern geraucht. Ja. Und ja, ich durfte auch darauf sitzen. Aber er hat am Ende gesagt, willst du noch ein Wasser haben? So als wäre, erst mal, gut, dass du es dringelassen hast, finde ich super. Aber das sind die Dinge, die er, ich liebe diese Interviews, wenn es mal menschelt. Nicht immer dieses Abgefrühstücke, drei Minuten. Und wenn du auch ganz menschlich sagst, nee. Nee, genau, das sind die tollen Informationen. Aber er hat das so gesagt, als wäre es vorher schon mal ein Thema gewesen, dass du ein Wasser bestanden hast. Ich hatte Wasser in der Hand. Ah, Glaswasser? Genau. Glasleitungswasser oder Sprudel? Leitungswasser. Leitungswasser. Egofluenza, richtige Egofluenza. Mhm. Und ging es denn nach dem Interview noch mal um Wasser, oder war das Thema dann auch vorbei? Wie viel Prozent der Redezeit ging es um Wasser eigentlich? Es klang so, als wäre es schon ein großes Thema gewesen. Es war auch wichtig zu sein. Hattest du zu dem Zeitpunkt noch Wasser im Glas? Nee, das war leer. Das war schon am Anfang ausgedrungen. Sahst du dehydriert aus oder sowas? Nee, er wollte, glaube ich, einfach noch nicht sein. Du hast alles direkt am Anfang ausgetrunken? Genau. Und er wollte vielleicht auch, dass ich das verschütte, auf seine teuren Möbel und es dann selber kaufen muss. Stimmt. Gibt es da so eine Regel, wer es beschädigt, muss es kaufen?
Ja. Ja, straight gelogen. Ja, auch mich an, gut, als wäre ich durch den Laden gelaufen, hätte das Bild beschädigt und dann nachher behauptet, ich hätte Kunst gekauft. Ja, schön. Aber waren die Bilder, die man dort kaufen kann, alle ungefähr so normale Bilder groß oder alle so riesengroß wie Stephans Wandbild? Die waren relativ klein, Es gab so normale Bilder, so was man sich hier vorstellt, und ganz kleine, so fünf Zentimeter mal zwanzig. Zwei, okay. Ja, also es gab kein riesiges Bild. Nee, Stephan hat das einzige wandgrosse Riesenbild also ersteigert, dass es dort gab. Ich habe in der Zwischenzeit noch ein anderes Bild ersteigert. Hast du das live dort eigentlich gesehen? Neeh, nee, nee. Das geht schon, die haben halt so einen Showroom, aber da war ich nicht vorher, nee. Aber die fotografieren das halt mit sehr vielen Bildern vorher, sehr, sehr sorgfältig. Du hast noch ein Bild ersteigert? Ja, in der Zwischenzeit habe ich ein anderes. Du hast es aber nicht auf die Frage der Fehlkäufe genannt, von daher bin ich guter Dinge. Nee, das ist ein schönes Bild. Ja, ich finde schon. Zeig mal, also ist das jetzt deine Phase, deine Kunstsammlerphase? Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Phase ist, ich habe mich immer schon für Kunst interessiert, und jetzt wo ich gesehen habe, dass man sich cool ersteigern kann, mit Online-Aufizumshäusern, gerne. Und ist es wieder so gross geworden oder hast du diesmal offen die Grösse geachtet? Es ist relativ gross. Ist es auch so traurig, so ein trauriger Vibe, wie das Bild, das du letztens ersteigert hast? Ähm Finde es traurig? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ah, guck mal, jetzt sehe ich das Bild. Aha, ist aber ein gutes Stück, abstrakter würde ich sagen, als das erste. Einmal ein Meter. Und das ist jetzt aber... Ich finde es ein bisschen komisch. Einmal ein Meter, eingerahmt, Leinwand. Hängen die direkt nebeneinander, oder wie hast du die angeordnet? Verschiedene Räume. Originale Kunstwerke zu zu haben ist wie viel schön ist. Und wie heißt der Künstler von dem zweiten Bild? Herbert Jacobi. Aber wenn du richtig zugehört hättest in meinem Interview, hättest du vielleicht mitbekommen, dass die meisten Künstler das gar nicht mehr selber malen, die grossen, sondern nur ihre Lehrlinge malen lassen und dann ihre Signatur unten drauf knallen und dann ist es einfach Goch. Aber ist Herbert Jacobi ein bekannter Name? Nee, aber nee, ich glaube, der... Ab dieser Folge? Es gibt einen berühmten Herbert Jacobi, aber das ist der, glaube ich nicht. Nee, aber es ist ein Straftäter, der die Schlecker-Erpressungen gemacht hat. Ah. Von der Jahreszahl kommt es ungefähr hin, lustigerweise. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst.ellt. Also nächstes Thema für die nächste Interviewreihe. Ist das dieselbe Person? Aber mir geht es ja nicht um, wer das gemalt hat, ehrlich gesagt. Bei diesen Bildern, die man da ... Also ich investiere da nicht rein. Ich will einfach nur schöne Bilder in meiner Wohnung hängen. Kannst du eigentlich Bilder so stundenlang ansehen? Ich sehe das in einem Museen, wo Leute so 20 Minuten vor einem Bild stehen. Ja, also vor allem mit den richtigen Hintergrundinformationen finde ich es total spannend. Also wenn du einen coolen Audioguide hast und wenn du nichts darüber weisst, ist ein Bilder, ist es total selten, dass man ein Bild einfesselt. Aber mit einer coolen Hintergrundinformationen ist es auf jeden Fall total schön, sich lange auf ein Bild einzulassen. Schön. Ja. Übrigens, tolle Ausstellung in Köln, kann man auch mal sagen. Es war einmal in Amerika, über amerikanische Kunst. Das ist ganz toll, im Wallraff-Richards-Museum. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind zu einem Werbepodcast geworden. Naja, aber sowas kann man mir empfehlen. Ich finde, wir haben gute Arbeit geleistet, wir haben gute Werbung gemacht heute. Das war die letzte Folge mit Thais, tatsächlich, für ihr erstes Praktikum. Wir haben viele Nachrichten bekommen, ihr seid sehr grosse Thais-Fans, wie wir natürlich auch. Wir gucken mal, wie es in Zukunft weitergeht, ob sie weitere Reportagen für uns machen. Und überleg doch mal einen eigenen Podcast zu machen, so einen Reportage-Podcast. Ja, vielleicht eine gute Idee. Du hast ja jetzt einiges an Geld vom Sponsoring, du kannst jetzt Mikrofone kaufen und so, und da kannst du ein eigenes Projekt starten. Ansonsten war es das mit deinem Schülerpraktikum. Ja, danke. Morgen und übermorgen bist du noch da, aber von den Folgen her ... Vielen, vielen Dank für deine Arbeit für uns. Du hast das Leben viel leichter gemacht. Wir waren echt total skeptisch, als wir uns klar wurden, dass du tatsächlich vorbeikommst. Und bis gestern waren wir auch wahnsinnig skeptisch. Nee, aber ich finde, es hat super geklappt und du hast echt super Arbeit geleistet und man hat sofort gemerkt, dass du irgendwie gut reinpasst und das gut funktioniert von daher. Du hast dieselbe Aufgaben beschafft, du hast es am Ende zwei, drei Rügen bekommen. Ja, aber das ist okay. Das gehört auch dazu. Man macht auch Fehler in dem Alter. Nee, das ist echt gut gemacht. Cool. Und wir hoffen natürlich auch, dass wir deinen Praktikumsbericht bekommen, den du schreibst über uns. Wenn ich ihn selber vorlesen darf. Du kannst ihn von mir gerne vorlesen. Ja, und reiche uns gerne Beiträge ein. Und ich denke, mit dem 700 Euro kommst du ja erst mal ein bisschen weit. Also ich hätte damals mit 700 Euro, mit 16 Jahren kommt man auf jeden Fall weit. Ich glaube, davon kann man sich ein Gemälde erscheinen, oder? Viele Matschbrötchen, viele Matschbrötchen hätte ich mir am Kiosk gekauft. Oh ja. Was sind Matschbrötchen? Die mit dem Schoko-Kussbrötchen, das ist einfach widerlich. Uns heißt das Fortuna-Brötchen. Fortuna-Brötchen, wirklich? Ja, weil es aussieht wie ein Fussball. Es schmeckt auch nie, also niemand isst es, weil es wirklich schmeckt, es sind einfach nur geballte Kalorien. Ich finde es gut. Echt jetzt? Ich finde es widerlich, ich habe es nicht mehr geholt. Dann Leute, macht es gut, rettet die Erde mit Bracenet, es ist eine fantastische Aktion. Wenn du eine Taube seht, einfach mal schön reintreten. Ab nächste Woche sehen wir einige von euch dann in Wien, mit der nächsten Live-Folge in Wien. Oh ja, freu mich sehr drauf. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Thais, alles Gute für deine Zukunft. Du wirst das machen, wir freuen uns davon, von dir weiteres zu hören, von deiner Regie-Karriere. Wir hoffen, dass die Phase ein bisschen länger andauert als die Punk-Phase.
Ansonsten viel Erfolg.
Und was tun wir jetzt?
Wir heben ab.